blind guy dating five girls based on
their outfits these are always very
cringe and very fun i love them let's
watch it in your lifetime probably too
many to count too many to count yeah but
i might not ghost you might not ghost me
oh i've seen a korean version of these
it just hit me and it was super
surprising the results oh interesting
okay i'm in
come on garrett
some money garrett forgot to put on a
t-shirt underneath his shirt who do you
think you are garrett you're not that
guy gary listen here gary put on a
shirt are you you're just going
to sweat down that shirt that's gross
you're gross you're sweaty boy brown i
graduated college a couple years what up
my name is garrett brown i'm too cool to
wear a t-shirt and i'm shut up
i might have been projecting a little
bit onto garrett i apologize there was a
guy at my high school never wearing
t-shirts i didn't like him i apologize
garrett it's not your fault i'm only
working on an app to help out some
charities i do value women who can dress
you know not up to standards but as long
as they're comfortable with what they're
wearing and they feel good what they're
wearing that's all i never met a guy
that cares what a woman wears
in my entire life
i never heard a guy say hey have you
seen what that girl is wearing
oh actually i do all the time women in
in uk oh my god what is wrong with women
in this country i live in a hellhole no
one understands that they did how do i
formulate what i'm trying to say it's so
windy in brighton okay it's
windy and it's cold all the time but god
bless the women here in this country
because they don't seem to give a
they'll still walk out and skirt and
t-shirt like it's nobody's business
anytime i'm driving down the seafront
and the wind is just like gushing
everyone yeah i don't get it i don't get
it i mean i get it but i don't get it
okay
all right so we have a wide variety of
some personalities here
i'm liking what i see a lot
you guys are setting me up very well
right now on some blind dates man is
everyone wearing sneakers i didn't
realize girls were sneakers so much
what's your name my name is liz liz nice
to meet you nice to meet you i'm garrett
are we wearing this as an everyday shoe
or is this a dress-up shoe yeah this is
an everyday shoe i'd probably wear this
to unless you're on that's going to be
too complicated you get a girl with
complicated shoes to get a girl with
complicated life everyone knows this
work or on a night out with the girls
look like how crazy are we getting 10
tequila
right so i'm getting blocked out by
hanging out with her so that's good to
know it's okay i'll take care of you oh
there we go music to my ear
what is this uh
this is beard line he's like i'll just
make a cut here so people know where my
hair cut ends and my beard ends
this guy
right there
those the left of me those are dungs
these are air force
ones all right so do you can see
these are air
or what what yourself to be a
fashionable person i'm more of like a
comfortable straight style type of
person okay so you're active on depop
no no no all right
this is going great
number three there's the dunk girl yes
girl do you have a name i like their
shoes those are nice shoes you must be a
depop girl i remember like the air force
once i'm sorry i'm sorry
geez the first two are out i bet you
they're really ugly unfortunately no man
i'm just whipping right now do i know
anything so what do you consider
yourself your style to be like i'm more
into
why
that's the dumbest question you could
possibly ask you're going to see their
style
ask about the personalities right
what's your style that's the whole point
that you get to see their style oh my
god
japanese lifestyle called wabi-sabi okay
embracing the imperfect that looks kind
of ugly i don't know all right beautiful
i'm excited to learn a little bit more
about that number four you're hiding
your shoes is that for a good reason or
a bad reason you know what you know what
let's not judge straight off this isn't
the main part of the outfit you know
have to let go of toronto
what
what's wrong with the shoes they look
normal
oh no
you're
nice kidding
meet you all right well i'm very sorry
your outfit is awesome thank you what
are you like six five
you're not six one you're absolutely
the devastation
oh god
you're just short
okay see what happens when you see what
happens they turn on you just like that
right i'll tell you anything you want to
hear and i'll turn on this all right
no there's no way oh that's hilarious he
only seemed generally disappointed by
that first cut i mean damn yeah except
that she got absolutely roasted your
outfit is awesome thank you what are you
like six five
we're the same height what are you like
669 feet tall you must be a giant or
something however
oh so good all right moving on to pants
i'm liking what i'm seeing
all right i stand by what i said before
left
number one and number two you're right
you're done what the hell are those
pants what the hell are those pants
why is pants the one item
that we buy to be be worn out of all
things distress right is it to show that
we live some sort of hardcore lifestyle
cause me and ken watched a video of a
toyota hilix people should really buy
like really messed up cars then right
by the same logic why don't you buy like
the most up car and be like look
yeah i i'm hardcore huh does that make
sense i don't understand humanity okay i
don't get it and help me we're oriented
okay so
yeah
nice
number one man what'd you get yeah
number two three and four they're good
number one and two you gotta get rid of
it i'll turn you on your side so you
won't throw up after the night of
drinking you know give you some soup
some soup and you'll turn me on my side
so i can throw up on the floor instead
of the bed well i'll put the trash can
there so i don't have to clean it up you
can take it out moving on a number two
how many men have you ghosted in your
lifetime probably too many to count too
many to count yeah but i might not go
see you might not ghost me i like the
whole charity he looks a bit like
charlie i picked me up too much now all
right maybe just me what does your
relationship with your dad look like my
dad yeah i'm a big daddy's girl he's
like my best friend big daddy's girl
it's your relationship with your dad
that's such a
i love these psychoanal analytical
questions you seem distracted
disinterested distant disappointed and
possibly destroyed after toronto cut
poor dude number three
i wasn't expecting those pants they look
very good i like them they sit well what
kind of pants are those they're corduroy
it it's actually overalls okay so it's
one piece up top
why do you think you're single right now
just truly just
what is your sexual drive what is your
libido did you experience any sexual
trauma as a young adolescent
i always say like i dress like elevated
casual like i want to look put together
but i want to look comfortable and like
i could fit in in like any scene and
then where'd you say you were from i'm
from kansas city i'm i'm getting um no
you know i'm just sitting there just
like this like when i go home now i
definitely get some like looks like
kind of some disapproving ones sometimes
based on what i get rid of one
unfortunately number one scares me a
little bit
the drinking the she knows what we're
going to be throwing up so we're
drinking a lot and i'm trying to get
past that you know i'm trying to
do well for myself
yeah good call she's weird oh hey hello
i'm liz nice to meet you nice to meet
you i'm sorry we can't go out clubbing
it's okay you know come here is she
wearing those eyelashes
or is those eyelashes wearing her jesus
christ thank you you're very beautiful
as well holy those are wings
dude she could flap away with those and
i'm taking another l today here ladies
and gentlemen
bye bye
bye looks so depressed he's still
thinking about the first girl he just
can't believe he messed up that bad
he's he doesn't want to play there we go
see now i'm starting to picture
more what they look like i get an actual
understanding of their personality a
little more
so number one now what are your
red flags and men so i can make sure
that i do not they all look decently
dressed i would say i am not a fan of
either i don't know fall into those you
have to be funny i'm really sarcastic
probably people take it as me sometimes
so you have to give my humor will you
make me cry on a date probably
what is all this weird question what do
you mean it will make me quiet will we
wipe my ass
thank you i think it looks great i love
the brown if you could pick
one thing about your dream guy that
matters the most to you what would it be
and why literally just like being
open-minded and open to trying new
things what kind of things you think you
could introduce me to new food new music
i'm really into
indian food at the moment and like
mediterranean and ethiopian food all
right now you're right last one you're
around you're right can i hurt my ankle
would you be able to carry me to safety
oh yeah firemen carry over the shoulder
fireman carry all right so we got a
stronger right there i'm with that
oh now he's got a pig
i guess that makes sense what else can
you reveal no
it's just so hard cause i like all of
them they all have great outfits and
i've been oh for two so far so that just
makes me feel even better knowing that
i'm gonna mess it up again so
unfortunately
number two the middle one will be the
first one that i'll be letting go today
i can't look okay and i can't do it
again i can't do it
oh hey
he's like oh thank god you're ugly gary
nice to meet you i'm so sorry for
letting you go you look absolutely great
hopefully in the future sweet you can
put me onto some more of that food and
some music all right thank you
oh
the last person i will be letting go is
drum roll please do you have any drums
in here
[Music]
unfortunately number one i will be
letting number one i got him today yeah
you should have gone sooner
come on are you kidding me
i'm so sorry
i love the bucket hat you were hiding
that under there come on now it was nice
meeting you if only i knew she had a
bucket hat this would have changed
everything look in the future thanks
i'll try
i'm sweating doing this man this is
heartbreaking i don't want to do this
all right
hey
karen kaylee nice to meet you nice to
meet you too
it's finally nice to see you yes you do
as well i love the outfit it looks great
i love the change you're like how i like
to describe myself like elevated casual
like you got the ysl and you got some
clean shoes but you're still like super
comfy looking and like i know you're
comfortable in what you're wearing you
know absolutely all right perfect yeah
that's true he kind of picked the girl
with the same style as him imagine if
you said another l after the last one
when he eliminated all the sims for the
tyrande girl when you live in the first
hottie it even hurt me i didn't even
play
why would you live those shoes were like
the best shoes she's like the only one
not wearing nikes right toronto
what are you like six five
forgot about that that's funny this kind
of made me feel like
outfits really don't matter like damn
they could have looked anyway
right it made no difference there's
something about him that sucks but i
can't put my finger on it there's some
people for what they wear is probably
one of the pillars of why society is
we trust the wrong people
because what is this a thing people
judge what they're wearing you do that
when you're like a teenager not not an
adult i'd be really curious to see the
other way around this how girls judge
guys i remember when i was younger girls
always told me like oh i always look at
the guy's shoes and if they're really
worn that means he's a piece of i
don't know like what girls look at my
shoes what what what the video what does
that mean
anyway if you want to look good every
single time check out pewdiepie merch
just kidding it's uh it's all that oh
actually this is perfect now i can uh we
have a new epic
drop for tsuki mischief collection
looking very nice the feedback uh
on this has been great check it out link
in the description and see you next time
bye